hatim entre voilà je t'en prie assieds
toi tous ses biens solennel ben oui
c'est une drôle de situation pour moi
parce que je l' ai déjà vécu avec mon
père quand je venais d'avoir 21 ans et
après ma vie a été transformé à jamais
donc je les aborde avec un peu de
d'appréhension d'accord je t'écoute tout
ça à l'air bien mystérieux bien
timidement fils chéri tout très
simplement les offres de notre famille
ont depuis toujours la capacité de tu
vas trouver ça très étrange attentes ou
à un truc étrange prépare-toi avoir la
chair de poule
voilà nous avons un secret de famille et
le secret c'est que les hommes de la
famille peuvent voyager dans le temps
enfin plus exactement voyager dans le
passé on ne peut pas voyager dans
l'avenir une blague tellement étrange
cela deux sérieusement rien d'une blague
alors tu dis que que toi et grand père
et ses frères
vous avez tous pu voyager dans le passé
absolument
et tu le fais toujours absolument bien
que ce soit moins spectaculaire que
c'est un honneur je reste dans ma vie je
peux aller uniquement aux endroits où je
me suis déjà trouvé que je me rappelle
je peux pas tuer hitler ou sauter hélène
de troie
malheureusement mon âge disons que c'est
vrai alors que ça allait pas bien que je
le sois bien et que ça soit forcément
pas mais disons que ça là il fallait pas
les seuls noms mais supposons que c'est
vrai comment je fais pour lui commencé
la partie facile tu te mets quelque part
dans le noir le grand placard font très
bien la faire mes toilettes faute de
mieux
ensuite tu sers les points si tu penses
au moment où tu veux aller étudier tout
revoir après un bref passage où ça tape
ça tremble et sa troupe
à